mesdames et messieurs l'amélioration
relative mais réel de la situation
sanitaire et les mesures renforcé de
protections aux frontières nous
permettent aujourd'hui de confirmer la
reprise des enseignements scolaires la
semaine prochaine comme l'avait annoncé
le président de la république dès ce
lundi 26 avril tous les élèves des
écoles maternelles élémentaires ainsi
que leurs enseignants regagneront leurs
classes fidèle en cela à notre objectif
depuis la fin du premier confinement
d'assurer aux élèves la continuité de ce
lien physique le plus qu'il soit
possible cette semaine du 26 avril doit
permettre donc un retour de tous les 1
physiquement les écoliers les autres à
distance les collégiens et les lycéens
ensuite il y aura donc la semaine du 3
mai c'est le retour en classe pour les
collégiens et pour les lycéens
l'enseignement sera hybride en lycée
autrement dit il y aura ce que ont déjà
connu beaucoup de lycéens c'est à dire
un enseignement en demies jauge la
moitié des lycéens qui viennent et
l'autre ensuite c'est selon un système
qui est organisé à l'échelle de chaque
lycée on aura donc un peu d'enseignement
à distance là aussi pour les lycéens
concernés services en et collégiens ils
rentrent au collège normalement donc
pleinement simplement pour les élèves de
4e et de 3e des quinze départements les
plus touchés par l'épidémie que vous
avez qui doivent s'afficher qui sont le
nord l'aisne l'oise les yvelines la
seine-et-marne seine-saint-denis les
hauts-de-seine le val-d'oise le
val-de-marne l'essonne
paris la sarthe la loire le rhône et les
bouches du rhône
donc dans ces départements les élèves de
quatrième et de troisième seront aussi
en 2011